uh what do you what do you think is the
meaning of this whole thing
is like is there a non-numerical oh okay
location yeah well really i think what
douglas adams was saying in hitchhiker's
guide to the galaxy is that
the universe is the answer
and
uh
what
we really need to figure out are what
questions to ask about the answer that
is the universe yeah
and that the question is the really the
hard part and if you can properly frame
the question then the answer relatively
speaking is easy
so
so therefore if if you want to
understand
what
questions to ask about the universe you
want to understand the meaning of life
we need to
expand the scope and scale of
consciousness
so that we're better able to
understand the nature of the universe
and
and understand the meaning of life
and ultimately the most important part
would be to ask the right question
yes uh
thereby elevating the role of the
interviewer
yes exactly as the most important human
in the room
good questions are
you know it's a hard it's hard to come
up with good questions
uh absolutely um
but yeah like it's like that that is the
foundation of my philosophy is that
um i i am curious about the nature of
the universe and
uh
you know and obviously i will die
i don't know when i'll die but i won't
live forever um
but i would like to know that we are on
a path to understanding the nature of
the universe and the meaning of life and
what questions to ask about the answer
that is the universe
and
and so if we expand the scope and scale
of humanity and consciousness in general
um which includes silicon consciousness
then
that you know there were that that seems
like a fundamentally good thing
elon like i said
um i'm deeply grateful that you would
spend your extremely valuable time with
me today and also that you are given
millions of people hope in this
difficult time this divisive time
in this uh cynical time so i hope you do
continue doing what you're doing thank
you so much for talking today oh you're
welcome uh thanks for excellent
questions
you